the hardest test I've ever had to take I
guarantee most Americans would have no
idea how to answer any of these
questions well G passed it so how hard
which is insane like I can't how did you
do it was real easy for me really
easy before the test they do like a
background check test where they ask me
things like are you a habitual
drunkard and I said well I was last
night and my lawyer was in the room and
he was like
have I ever been a prostitute was
another question they asked you that
yeah and I said well I was no
I'm I think the people asking those
questions the officials think well this
will be the time that someone would come
clean when they're trying to get
citizenship